[Musica]
[Applauso]
18 minuti
ai 18 minuti così mi hanno detto sono
tanti 18 minuti per L'emozione che provo
sono pochissimi 18 minuti per tutto
quello che vorrei dirvi
poi penso per fortuna che me l'hanno
detto che io solo 18 minuti altrimenti
avrei iniziato a dirvi parole su parole
pensando di avere tempo e invece questo
mio tempo con voi avrà una fine questo
mio tempo con voi ha un limite
è così limite non posso cambiarlo questo
limite non posso andare oltre Eppure
questo limite qui in questo momento per
me è importante anzi direi fondamentale
perché mi ha permesso di guardarmi
dentro cercare le cose importanti quelle
che per me hanno un senso un significato
un valore quello che davvero vorrei
trasmettervi
mi capita così in fondo ogni volta che
mi confronto con una fine o con una
porta che si chiude Eppure proprio
quella fine quella porta chiusa mi fa
scoprire altre strade
mi fa conoscere cose nuove mi spinge a
cercare l'aiuto degli altri e non
sentirmi sola mi fa trovare risorse che
non pensavo di avere
Sarà capitato anche a voi Probabilmente
di vivere situazioni simili la fine di
una relazione un lavoro che si cambia
una malattia
sono momenti difficili dolorosi spesso
faticosi da attraversare e spesso è
proprio lì in quei momenti che ha inizio
un cambiamento una trasformazione una
crescita interiore
ho lavorato per molti anni Presso
un'azienda che era per me la mia seconda
casa
un giorno il capo mi chiama nel suo
ufficio e mi propone un cambio di
mansione o meglio una promozione un
avanzamento di carriera in quel preciso
momento una vocina da dentro si
impossessa di me e dice non lo so
come non lo sai È quello che hai
desiderato ed aspettato per anni
Eh non lo so
ci ho messo tempo per perdonare quella
voce che in un attimo stava mandando
all'aria tutti i miei piani
Perché in fondo la vita l'avevo vista un
po' così un cammino senza interruzioni
un continuo andare avanti di obiettivi
da raggiungere e mi riusciva pure bene
un momento di difficoltà il primo anno
di università vero ma non avevo avuto la
forza di fermarmi non potevo perdere un
anno nel corso del tempo poi erano
arrivati altri momenti di delusione
tristezza a volte insoddisfazione ma non
avevo saputo ascoltare quelle emozioni
non avevo potuto cogliere il messaggio
che avevano per me
andiamo avanti cercando stimoli nuovi
mi ero aggiustata alle cose che stavano
accadendo in quel momento
non accontentata ma aggiustata sì
rincorrevo il desiderabile che la mia
mente mi proponeva invece di ascoltare
ciò che desideravo davvero e quella voce
quel giorno davanti al capo era arrivata
lì per ricordarmelo perché mi parlava di
un cambiamento profondo che stava
avvenendo dentro di me mi parlava di una
cosa importante che avevo messo da parte
mi parlava di un senso diverso che
volevo dare al mio tempo
quel Non lo so che io giudicavo così
incauto In realtà mi stava ricordando
che pur nel mio continuo affaccendarmi e
correre la mia vita in quel momento era
ferma bloccata girava su se stessa
ora so che quella vocina in realtà era
molto più vitale ed anche molto più
saggia di quello che pensavo perché da
quel momento in poi è iniziato un
cambiamento che ha stravolto
completamente la mia sfera professionale
e come potete immaginare anche la mia
vita
Ma sapete perché ci ho messo tempo a
perdonare ed anche ad ascoltare quella
voce
perché avevo paura di accettare che una
parte della mia vita fosse finita di
lasciarla andare di aprirmi al nuovo e
non conosciuto
avevo paura di cambiare radicalmente il
lavoro e di lasciar andare l'identità
che quel lavoro portava con sé una
dimensione rassicurante che nella mia
mente suonava un po' così questa sono io
e questa è la mia vita
avevo paura della fine
Ma se ci chiudiamo di fronte a un
compimento di fronte a una chiusura di
fronte alla fine rischiamo di rimanere
ciechi di fronte al nostro fine al
nostro scopo al nostro senso
provate ad immaginare un film senza
finale
non una serie a puntate ma proprio un
film che non ha mai fine
siete in sala passano le ore durante le
quali si avvicendano personaggi vicende
fatti e voi siete lì ad aspettare che
sullo schermo appaia questo fatidico the
end che non arriva mai
Come vi sentite di fronte ad un film che
non finisce mai
Immagino che ad un certo punto sarete
voi a dire basta e ve ne andrete tornate
a casa e cosa pensate Cosa vi manca il
finale Certo ma vi manca ancora di più
la possibilità di ripercorrere nella
vostra mente i momenti di quel film Alla
luce di quel finale che non c'è vi manca
di poter creare una storia di dargli un
senso il senso il messaggio che quel
regista voleva darvi
come nell'immagine del film se io mi
fossi aggrappata ancorata a quello che
stavo vivendo Se non avessi accettato
quella fine quel compimento quella
chiusura non mi sarei aperta il senso di
quel Non lo so e al senso di quel
cambiamento che stava per iniziare
avete mai osservato come i bambini
vivono le loro emozioni
sono al parco sulla panchina a fianco a
me c'è una mamma con un bambino in
braccio il bambino piange disperato
senza quasi riprendere fiato gli hanno
rubato il posto in altalena
qualche minuto dopo si avvicina una
signora con un cagnolino in cerca di
coccole il bambino si accorge subito del
cucciolo smette di piangere e in un
attimo il suo viso si accende di
entusiasmo
È così che i bambini rimangono in
contatto con la fluidità della vita
Appunto
sono capaci in modo naturale di
lasciarsi attraversare pienamente dalle
emozioni di viverle tutte con grande
intensità e poi di lasciarle andare una
volta che hanno seguito il loro corso
non si chiedono cosa sia giusto o
sbagliato provare
accolgono e vivono tutto con la stessa
intensità per questo sono costantemente
aperti a ciò che accade fuori al loro
sentire
In fondo anche per me un cambiamento era
stato possibile solo quando avevo
accettato quella fine solo quando mi ero
permessa di provare tutte le emozioni
che in quella fine c'erano dentro
lo so non è facile per noi nemmeno
immaginare che nel dolore possa esserci
qualcosa di prezioso per noi qualcosa di
vivo
nel volerci felici a tutti i costi la
felicità A volte diventa una condanna
quasi una gabbia
evitiamo la tristezza la paura la
frustrazione non ci concediamo il tempo
di vivere il nostro dolore
Eppure la gioia la speranza la fiducia
ritornano nelle nostre vite solo quando
abbiamo avuto la possibilità di
ascoltare e accogliere e solo allora
trasformare quel dolore quella paura
Quella tristezza
una felicità che non include la
possibilità di vivere quelle emozioni
che noi definiamo negative è una
felicità estremamente fragile ed Ina
autentica
rifiutare quelle emozioni significa
negare parti di noi mutilare il nostro
sentire che poi è la fonte della nostra
stessa vitalità come dimostrano i
bambini ed è anche una bussola
indispensabile per muoverci nella vita
lo scorso anno mi sono trovata ad
affrontare una malattia molto importante
da quell'esperienza ho portato con me
una lezione significativa avevo il
diritto di avere paura di avere dolore
Anzi ne avevo bisogno e avevo bisogno di
dirlo e avevo bisogno che qualcuno
restasse con me con quelle emozioni
senza andarsene e Senza voler cambiare
nulla perché sentivo che se potevo
starci con quelle emozioni potevo farne
qualcosa
perché quelle emozioni difficili
sicuramente
parlavano della mia vita parlavano alla
mia vita
ora che ad affrontare una malattia e una
persona a me molto cara quella lezione
me la tengo stretta perché mi aiuta a
Non fuggire mi aiuta a stargli vicina
Ci sono momenti difficili dolorosi
Eppure allo stesso tempo ci sono momenti
intimi profondi parole dette ed
ascoltate che non sono state possibili
prima
è un tempo che si ferma e si dilata
perché non ci sarà sempre tempo
è un tempo che non si passa ma si vive
sono Momenti Preziosi importanti Eppure
io stessa in questo momento ho un po' di
pudore nel parlarvi di questa bellezza
perché so che questa bellezza non può
essere slegata dal dolore e dalla
tristezza di una situazione che vivo
La cosa difficile per me in questo
momento è lasciarmi attraversare Come
fanno i bambini da tutto ciò che arriva
accogliere con la stessa apertura
emozioni così contrastanti
Perché quando mi apro a sentire
l'intensità e la pienezza di certi
momenti
inevitabilmente sono in contatto anche
con la tristezza e la difficoltà di
questa situazione
Ma se decidessi di anestetizzarmi se
decidessi di chiudermi di fronte al
dolore alla paura mi chiuderei anche
davanti alla bellezza e la ricchezza che
questa stessa situazione porta con sé mi
chiuderei davanti alla vita
mentre pensava cosa vi avrei detto
questa sera mi sono tornate spesso alla
mente le parole di una psicoterapeuta
marine in gel quando descrive il suo
lavoro di cura accanto ai malati
terminali quelle parole vorrei leggerle
con voi
dopo aver per anni assistito gli infermi
nei loro ultimi istanti non ho appreso
niente di più sulla morte in se stessa
ma la fiducia nella vita non ha fatto
che crescere vivo senza dubbio più
intensamente con Maggiore coscienza ciò
che mi è dato di vivere gioie e dolori
ma anche tutte le piccole cose
quotidiane ovvie come il semplice fatto
di respirare o di camminare
così dopo anni di assistenza coloro che
definiamo moribondi e che invece sono
vivi fino all'ultimo mi sento più viva
che mai E lo devo a coloro che ho
accompagnato negli ultimi istanti e che
nell'umiltà in cui li ha precipitati la
sofferenza si sono rivelati maestri
Ho scelto questa testimonianza toccante
per portare qui con voi quasi alla fine
del nostro tempo insieme la grande
transizione la morte
una morte che oggi è sempre più
mediatica pubblicizzata strumentalizzata
abusata svenduta Eppure è la grande
assente di questo nostro secolo e del
nostro Occidente è la mordidita la morte
proibita di cui non si può e non si deve
parlare perché se è vero che di morte si
parla è sempre la morte di una guerra di
un incidente di un fatto accaduto ma non
è mai qualcosa che ci riguarda non è mai
qualcosa che riguarda la nostra
esistenza
ho parlato di limite di compimento di
dolore di fine e dunque di morte e di
come cancellare tutto questo dal nostro
Orizzonte significa negare ogni
transizione ogni trasformazione ogni
cambiamento ogni crescita il fluire
stesso della vita e allora è della vita
che stiamo parlando della nostra vita
nelle cose per noi importanti essenziali
urgenti di quello che noi per noi ha più
valore del senso che alla Vita vogliamo
dare
vorrei lasciarvi con una breve
esperienza che faremo insieme
vi chiedo di accomodarvi sulla vostra
sedia
di fare un bel respiro profondo
e di chiudere gli occhi sapendo che
potete aprirli in qualsiasi momento
vorrete
immaginate che la vita voglia farvi un
regalo
vivrete 150 anni
immaginate che da un certo punto in poi
la vostra vita sia bella ed appagante
che riuscirete ad esprimere pienamente
voi stessi
a prescindere da ciò che vi accadrà
immaginate che il campo passi ed
immaginate di arrivare al vostro ultimo
giorno perché anche quella vita lunga ed
appagante come i miei 18 minuti finirà
immaginate di essere al vostro ultimo
giorno
vi chiedo come volete ricordare quel
luglio 2022 della vostra vita
con tutte le difficoltà che state
affrontando le circostanze le situazioni
ma anche le cose belle come volete
ricordare voi stessi
nell'affrontare tutto questo
che ricordo di voi vi piacerebbe avere
in quell'ultimo giorno quando
ripenserete indietro a questo periodo
Vi chiedo che ricordo di voi Vi farebbe
stare bene in pace Se voi avesse avuto
Quale atteggiamento quale comportamento
Quale energia in tutte le cose che state
vivendo
conservate tutto ciò che di buone è
arrivato da questa esperienza magari
un'immagine una sensazione
ora vi chiedo di fare un altro respiro
profondo
e di riaprire gli occhi
ricordate l'immagine del film senza
finale
bene
Vi auguro che quell'ultimo giorno con
quello che oggi Scegliete di essere
quell'ultimo giorno il finale del film
l'avrete deciso voi
Grazie
[Applauso]